[Music]
Wow being the last one on the last day
of the presentation in the sidetrack I'm
impressed that there are still people
here that are not sleeping it's
professionally what we call this slot
The Twilight Zone and I know that you
guys are tired after two days of
conferencing and learning and Java
scripting so I hope that this talk is
going to be a little fun for you that
said you know like I've added a few
jokes here and there but my wife tells
me that my dad jokes are absolutely
terrible so we'll see how that works out
for you guys nobody laughs that's a good
start
hi my name is Pierre and you might
remember me from such amazing projects
such as the Java servlet API the Java
API for XML Java SC Java 2 SC 1.5 and a
lot more Java goodness and I'm sure that
right now you're actually wondering
whether I am at the right conference
here well I am you see like a few years
back when I was living in Tokyo I met
this fine gentleman his name is judge
Schmidt that we were working together
and he's one of the creator or for
example Brookings yes is quite a famous
name over there and he you know thanks
to the beatings of this fine gentleman I
kind of like
praise the Lord I saw the light I
[Music]
abandoned the dark side and converted to
this wonderful world of nodejs let me
tell you life since then has been all
ponies and rainbows but I want to point
that one thing I know that I'm gonna
anger some of you here I am NOT a
general like I'm definitely not into
Star Wars I'm more of a Trekkie myself
so just in case but enough about me and
let's get into the nitty gritty details
of this talk so today we're talking
about the almighty toilet paper rolls
and now I'm sure they are really
wondering am i the right conference how
many of you are familiar with this
wonderful object I mean you know if not
this one we can get the black one it's
so Berlin you know amazing for your
health I really hope that you had a good
use of this today and you know but what
about JavaScript in about an toilet
paper well let's take a step back you
see a couple of years back I took a job
at a company called kirbeh kirbeh is a
big giant in industrial manufacturing
here in Germany they are one of the
largest manufacturer of industrial
machines including amongst a thousand
other things between tobacco machines
palletizing equipment and so on it's
work we actually do produce machines
that produce toilet paper and kitchens I
am embedded with their digital lab
Kerber digital and at herbert the guitar
we develop digital applications for our
customers right more specifically and I
am in a team that develops this
wonderful what we're building is called
kedge
kedge is an app that has been designed
to offer shift support in for the
operators of toilet paper machines right
on K edge as you can see there you know
like operators of operators of these
machines can actually see their
production stats like how many logs
they've produced the average speed at
which the machine is running down times
and whatnot they can see the telemetry
from the machine itself you can see
actually the graph over there we take
the graph we analyze the speed we create
yellow segments or red segments yellow
segments or reduced productivity so when
we are below that green line that you
see over there and the red segments is
when the machine is actually stopped so
what happens the operator at that point
has the ability to create a digital
report of their shift right so KH is
deployed as a on a tablet and that goes
alongside at the traditional HMI the HMI
is that big computer you see big there
that controls actually the machine
itself and the operators use the tablet
to create a digital journal of their
shift and you know replace their old
paper-based and trail of stuff right but
so let's look a little bit about how KH
is built so this is a quick outline of
our architecture the front end is a
react app and so lots of JavaScript and
it's deployed statically on Amazon s3
surf through plat front login and will
be handled by
kognito really soon and Bekah
communication goes through redux to a
bunch of javascript micro services which
have been deployed as Amazon lambda
functions and therefore accessible via
the AWS gateway interesting isn't it No
it's 2019 nobody cares about another
goddamn react app you know like if I
were to talk about this you might just
as well go out to the beach and you know
like catch some Sun while you can you
know enjoy the heat and so on and so
forth so what's actually interesting
about what we do well to figure that out
we have to see how toilet paper is
actually produced right so thanks to the
National Geographic
this is how a modern toilet paper
factory looks on the inside this has
been shot at softener which is one of
the biggest producers of toilet paper
here in the European market and you can
actually hear how loud this place is
right giant factories just to make
toilet paper but easier on the ears
let's look a little bit at how a
production line is actually and it's
actually configured this is a parading
machine one of ours wonderful piece of
equipment that runs at around 50
kilometers an hour and how how is
Philippe Purdue produce we start from
the top left with some giant jumbo rolls
we call them those are three tons of
paper 1 ply paper to put that into
perspective one of those rolls is enough
for at least three of you to make toilet
paper for the rest of your life so
pretty big we unwind those ones right we
unwind them one two or three or four of
them depending if we want to make one
ply toilet paper two three or four ply
toilet paper after the three of winders
that you see over here you we have what
is called the embosser the embosser
basically takes the supplies of toilet
paper pushes them together and embosses
this nice little pattern that you see
over here and in the process it injects
air into the paper so it makes it
thicker it makes it fluffier softer
gentler on your rear end maybe after the
paper is embossed basically what happens
is that the cardboard core here gets
produced by that machine that you see in
the middle over there the cardboard core
slides in and we actually start
rewinding the embossed paper around the
cardboard core in giant blocks a log is
around three meters it's like this but
it's three meters long right those ones
going to that thing that looks like a
cage which is an act
which is no more nor less than a buffer
decoupling the unwinding part on the top
from the cutting and packaging at the
rear end of the line you see at the very
top over there we have a log saw which
basically takes this log and took cuts
it makes these things and then quickly
the the left at the right of your screen
we see the package or basically you know
takes 4 8 12 toilet paper rolls put them
together wraps them around
nice package that you see on the
supermarket and at the bottom we have
the pallet Iser where all these packs
get stacked up put into a pallet boom
ready for shipping right so but now you
will be asking is all of this control
with JavaScript production a production
line a more even the modern production
lines are controlled by something called
a PLC or programmable logic controller I
like to call them legacy hardware from
the last century DC's last generation
siemens s7 1500 and top-of-the-line
great plc there is one little problem
with these beasts that they're still
programmed using a thing called ladder
logic this is an example of a program
but you know like in the PLC's
themselves we don't even have variables
in most of the PLC's we address
variables are there location in the
memory so we don't know exactly what
store here and there this is definitely
not for the faint of heart
programming one of those things is kind
of like mix make Scoble look it's sewn
20:19 you know and if it's not bad
enough we actually don't work on this
beautiful brand-new machines most of the
time we used on the machines that have
been in the field for like 10-15 years
this is normally how we find that appeal
this is Inga it's it's it's a machine
that I had to connect in order to
extract data from in order for our
application to work correctly right and
it's a jungle of wire and and how do we
extract data from this medial evil piece
of kit well we had more wires we add you
know like more wires and an industrial
PC in there which we call the gateway
and the gateway connects on one side to
the PLC with his beautiful Ethernet
cable and on the other side sent thanks
to our friends at Twilio you will see
them in the exhibitors lounge over there
we have a dedicated LTE connection that
pumps the data down to the cloud right
and this the Gateway is where we run all
these JavaScript goodness that we've
wrote but before we get into the
JavaScript part you know like I wanted
to show you a little bit the
connectivity scenario so on the Left we
have the little factory which is our PLC
well in the middle the chip is is our
gateway running node and bridge is kind
of like the time gap between you know
like the between the last century and
now and all the right well obviously we
have the cloud so the data flow here is
interesting because being stuck in the
past the PLC does not know anything
about encryption security not even a
password right if I can read from a PLC
I can write to it I can reprogram it I
can do whatever I want with it and the
only thing that I need to do that is an
IP address which I can connect now this
is very secure that has been used many
times in the past probably the most
famous cases when all the centrifuges in
in Iran for processing uranium's where
disabled by some malicious code by
simply destroying the the programming on
the PLC that spun up those centrifuges
and boom machine is gone right so but
when we push the data to apply we want
to make sure that everything is safe so
we started looking at the physical
boundaries
of security and so we install our
gateway into the cabinet where the PLC
is we only have one cable
nothing is in nothing it's out nobody
contacts the PLC from outside of the
cabinet of the PLC itself right and
outside when we want to reach through
the cloud you know like we have a nice
secure modern Linux base you know like
VPN on top of an LTE link so we actually
implement we actually define a security
perimeter around the PLC so that we can
protect it from attacks and we do this
by installing the Gateway within with a
PLC itself right the Gateway itself also
serves about another bunch of purposes
we want to consolidate data because as
much as their friends at Twilio
advertise their 4G in most cases
factories are you know they are not very
well in terms of receptions you most of
the times we get to G 40 kilobits a
second so that's not quite enough to
actually have a full stream of data
coming out so we actually do a lot of
data consolidation on the Gateway itself
that's why we need the processing power
of JavaScript to do that and so we send
only for example the data that that
changes in the PLC and we also do a lot
of cash so we do we cache everything
that we read on to the device itself
because well it's 2g wins and you know
whatever connectivity comes and goes and
so on and so forth in case of
connectivity failures and some hiccup
occurs we can quickly or as quick as it
can range s all the data that we have
right while the link goes down and then
continue with normal operation right so
we started this thing with a wonderful
program by IBM Research that was called
nude red node red is a wonderful tool
because it has libraries that allows us
to connect to the PLC and you see here a
very very easy configuration every 10
seconds we were in speed we read like a
thing that is called the first alarm we
shift it down to the right we send it
over and qtes to Amazon right this is
great nice GUI can do quickly things
very quickly so based in Java
it's amazing but gets really complicated
when we start reading like a bunch of
variables this is actually a real
configuration file that we had in
production when we started reading more
valuable the thing and it it really gets
a message becomes like a bunch of wires
you never know who is changing what we
cannot manage this these files and so on
and so forth right so a year ago roughly
it dawned on me I said you know well we
have the technology we ran rebuilding it
and we came up with a thing that is
called the PLC reader um
PLC reader is a wonderful little node.js
application that we ofwar we wrote in
order to clean up the mess that was node
red JavaScript why because node red was
supporting was built in node continue
with node because we had the reliability
over there but we managed to bring in
some automation in the world of pointing
clique right
it has a very simple job it reads values
from various sources which we call
drivers and processes in various ways
through a pipeline of what we call
processors right on top of that it's
easily deployed as a Debian package we
built a little tool called Debian eyes
and it's all managed all the
configuration is not point-and-click but
it's llamó files easy to manage get
central we can track who changes what
and we can deploy things with circle CI
and ansible to all our gateways and
whatnot right so let's look at one of
those configuration files very very
easily here we have one driver a driver
that guess what connects to a PLC a
siemens s7 PLC we have the IP address
and the port which we connect to you
know freedom right Iraq and slot our
particular parameters for the RFC 106
protocol that we are using to talk to
these things and what's important is
that every two seconds we read this
variable or better we read these memory
addresses at db5 one zero two
and at offsets 12 that's a word and
that's basically unsigned 16-bit integer
we call that speed so that's where we
find the speed at which the machine is
running at offsets 36 we see the code of
the first alarm and so on and so forth
this is one of the drivers we have many
other drivers which we wrote for example
to monitor the performance of our
Gateway itself so here I just listed you
know like load average every 10 seconds
we read the load average see few
percentages every 10 seconds we just
calculate the percentage of the CPU used
memory we also have latency to monitor a
beautiful Twilio connection and this is
how we get start getting data into the
system right what do we do with that
it's very easy we have a bunch of
processors which are organized in a
pipeline one after another each
processor can subscribe to one to many
all of the Verrill of the values that
are published by the drivers or are
republished by the by the processors and
here we have very simple example of
three processors that we are actually
using the first one is a function the
only line of JavaScript that probably
you will see my talk which takes the
speed which in the machine is published
in DISA meters per minute don't know why
but we divided by 10 in meters per
minute the great the second ones
stringify because you know like we read
alarms as unsigned 16-bit integers but
there are no actually numbers we cannot
make an average on an alarm code so we
convert them into strings and we
consolidate the stuff that I was telling
before so you know like if the alarm
changes then we publish it otherwise if
the alarm has not changed we swallow
that message right but the most
important property processors that we
have are you know like
two that we use at the end of the
pipeline The Bachelor and the MQTT won't
the Badger is very simply something that
subscribe to all the messages
accumulates them and every 30 seconds
pushes out that thing that you see like
over there message
oceans out a message which is no more
nor less than an array of times that
which data was read the name of the data
point and the value of the data point
giant array we also do compress it so
that it's nice and nice and tiny when we
send over our 2g link and then the mqtt
processor does what's supposed to be
doing sends it over to mqtt secure blah
blah blah variables this is how we use
javascript everything behind these at
yml file every processor every driver
the entire infrastructure to drive these
things is written in JavaScript and
we're using it like we're it's it's been
a labor of love we are extremely proud
that it's running in production at real
customers sites it's it's fitting kedge
with with live real data it has been
working out great if you are a dance you
know maybe you know how proud you are
the other thing that I mentioned there
were a couple of extra things enough for
the KITT llamo we've wrote a bunch of
llamo extensions which we needed for
these configuration files yeah Mel is
great but it's also terrible it doesn't
allow including it doesn't allow a bunch
of things so we wrote a little extension
over there to merge arrays of arrays so
if we have in one file define a list of
drivers and in another file another list
of drivers we can just merge them
together it works great obviously with a
next one which is the include driver so
we include a part a snippet of llamó
into another file making sure the
all the variables are visible by the
included files and whatnot so there is a
little bit of logic over there and then
the last one that you use a lot for
configuration is the join that takes an
array of values and concatenates them
into a giant string so it's great for
you know things like virulence a
certificate ID that repeats 25 million
times in in our configuration files
right
the other thing that I talked about was
deionized deionized is simply a little
tool that we wrote in order to take your
NPM package have it as a dead why
because we use Ubuntu on our gateways so
it was easy for us to just get one thing
out of the way you just slap it in your
package Jason and you just do an NPM run
debian is this is actually the
configuration of plc reader in itself
it's very complex
it has sensible defaults so it's a one
line of addition makes a debian package
so what's the state for us what's the
state of the onion and in terms of you
know like all the stuff that we've wrote
so far we have PLC reader which is open
source you can just check it out on NPM
we have DPN eyes that is ready out for
there and for everybody to use yamo
extensions as well open source you know
just get them download them even if you
don't care about PLC's or industrial
machines they're there they work we also
throw in like such because they are such
a good audience we also throw in a
freebie which is the RM DB per sister
iron BB is the time series database that
we use for telemetry data is a fantastic
time series database developed by a
friend of mine
filo Sanaa go and but they had no
JavaScript drivers for them so we've
wrote them and and they're also
available for you guys to use if you use
our DB and that's pretty much it for me
because I think that I have two minutes
and I was wondering if you guys have any
questions sure
even though the yellow files normally
was written by a programmer I don't see
you handing it over to the sales support
why didn't you just do that as some sort
of mental java sperm because that's
right because actually it is readable
enough that can be handled by presale
support because in most get through the
inclusions that's why we wrote the yamen
extensions there are parts that people
don't talk don't touch but for example
the list of addresses in the memory in
the plc that comes from an excel file
that the machine manufacturer actually
makes so that one is handled by a
different team when they change the PLC
programming they can just change that
part and then you know like all the rest
flows together so that's why we chose to
use Yama rather than then then
JavaScript for that yeah anything else
there was a question over there at the
bottom but you know like I guess that
nobody picks it up Wow such an amazing
question right I spent the first 15
years of my career building Java systems
I'm one of the cofounders of Jakarta and
the XML Apache projects I've been doing
Java since 1997 and for me it's it's
it's like PLC reader it's a labor of
love the problem over there is that we
have seen that there is an aggressive
actor in the Java world that is actually
starting to copyright and push their
copyright of the API is out and we're
talking about Oracle over there that
didn't give us confidence that what we
were building for especially in this
case when these gateways are over a 2g
link we didn't have the confidence that
we could update the Java Virtual Machine
every six months like Oracle wants us to
do kind of thing and I know that Amazon
came out with some wonderful things on
their site but I wonder how long those
are going to last in a court so
JavaScript on the other hand
you know ACMA pretty much every
implementation out there is open source
and it gives us the stability that we
need thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]